[Music]
on this Sunday night the struggle to get
out of Sudan
Canadian diplomats evacuated as fighting
rages but what about Canadian citizens
who have been told they're on their own
also tonight five years later painful
memories live on the violence and loss
of life will remain a scar on many of
our hearts looking back at one of
Canada's worst mass murders
toxic Time Bomb the deadly Discovery in
Alberta's oil sands it's not a matter of
who if but when the Chinese military
will will try and move on to Taiwan
we're one on one with taiwan's foreign
affairs minister talking China and
foreign interference
plus sharing everyday experiences
obviously there's not many of us at
least in chemical engineering the
special space giving back to black
students
global national
Bara Nasser
and thank you for joining us we begin
with the power struggle in Sudan and the
scramble to get Canadians out today
Ottawa temporarily suspended all
operations in Sudan as a situation in
the capital grows more desperate by the
day
deadly clashes between Sudan's armed
forces and a paramilitary group shows no
sign of letting up airports are under
siege and there's no obvious Escape
Route
but tonight we're learning new details
of a successful operation that did get
Canadian diplomats out of Sudan
in a tweet foreign affairs minister
Melanie Jolie says Canadian diplomats
are safe and they're working from a
location outside of the country now
where exactly Embassy staff are is not
yet known but nearly 1600 Canadians
stuck in Sudan have been told to shelter
in place because getting them out is
almost impossible Mike drolet has our
top story tonight
the distinctive rattle of gunfire echoed
throughout the Sudanese capital of
Khartoum again today as some locals
ventured out to scavenge for whatever
food and supplies they could find the
increasingly violent power struggle
between two Sudanese generals that began
just over a week ago shows no sign of
abating expats living in Khartoum
describe it as chaos everyone has been
stranded
there is no hope of survival everyone is
just running held to skater you know
looking for shelter
to survive Saudi Arabia was able to
evacuate more than 150 of its citizens
by ship on Saturday one of only a
handful of countries that were
successful the U.S and UK militaries
evacuated diplomatic staff from their
embassies it's unclear how but Canadian
diplomats have also left the country
that leaves roughly 1600 Canadians still
in Sudan late last night they received
to communique from Global Affairs Canada
offering that the situation is volatile
and that foreigners and staff of
international organizations have been
targeted the recommendation is that
Canadians shelter in place because no
air evacuations are possible at this
time and a stark reminder that no help
is coming keep in mind that you are
responsible for your own safety and that
of your family
the fighting was right outside Vesna
vukovich's apartment the Canadian
teacher had very little power or data
left on her phone today she told Global
News she was on a cramped bus headed to
the Egyptian border it's definitely
going to be a long and dangerous Journey
she said but at least we clearly
understood the message of our government
knowing that we are on our own she added
this is our only chance
she has a potentially harrowing journey
ahead as the fog of War continues to
hang over cartoon
microlight Global News Toronto
the public service Alliance of Canada is
ramping up its picketing targeting
locations such as ports starting
tomorrow
more than 100 000 members of the Union
walked off the job last Wednesday after
contract talks broke down the union
President says they will be moving
picket lines Beyond Office Buildings to
have more impact on government services
to Alberta now where Energy company
Suncor says it's discovered dozens of
dead wildlife and one of its sites north
of Fort McMurray tailings ponds hold
toxic Wastewater left over from the
production of fishermen tonight Heather
York's West on the calls for change
dressing the tailings challenge is
important to us as a company and to our
stakeholder for companies in the oil
sands the problem of tailings ponds has
proven to be a difficult nut to crack
the pools of Wastewater Now cover large
areas of the Boreal forest and on
Saturday Alberta's energy regulator
reported that at one of suncor's tailing
sites a number of animals had been
discovered dead originally the regulator
said the company found 32 birds at the
tailing site 28 kilometers north of Fort
McMurray but after further investigation
the company updated the total to 43
Birds two muskrats one bat and one vole
it wasn't a surprise because deadly bird
Landings on tailings ponds have been
happening if they've actually been
reported for decades 1600 Ducks died
when they landed on a tailings pond
operated by sin crude in 2008 and 31
great blue herons were killed at a soon
crude oil sands mine site in 20 15. more
recently 50 birds were killed after
landing on a site operated by Imperial
oil in 2020 oil sands are required to
have bird protection plans in place for
their operations and in a statement
Suncor says its bird deterrence
including cannons and radar were active
both Suncor and the AER are
investigating what went wrong the
incident comes in the same week that
Suncor reported a release of 6 million
leaders from a sedimentation Pond and
just days after the CEO of Imperial oil
apologized before a parliamentary
committee for a series of leaks at its
site at Coral Lake we are disappointed
in this recent performance
we can and will do better
I promise you that but the reality is
the problem of tailings Pawns has no
solution yet the Wastewater covers an
area the size of a small City with no
viable way to clean it up and that
cleanup question is one that Canada
hasn't solved and we really got to start
this conversation now because without
that conversation there's growing
concern more leaks spills and Wildlife
deaths could be ahead Heather your
Express Global News Calgary
on a sunny spring day five years ago a
man deliberately drove a van down a busy
sidewalk in Toronto committing one of
the country's worst mass murders
it was unfathomable then and still
shocking now to think how our innocence
as a community and as a city was lost
the violence and loss of life will
remain a scar on many of our hearts
especially those who today family and
friends gathered in Toronto to reflect
on the tragedy and to honor the people
who died in the attack in April of 2018.
16 others were injured including a woman
who died from her injuries more than
three years later
to Quebec now where the provincial
government is backtracking on a major
campaign promise
made a pledge to build a highway tunnel
under the Saint Lawrence River to
connect Quebec City Tel Aviv but as Mike
Armstrong explains that project is now
being scaled back
s Premier didn't do any favors for his
Transportation Minister sending her out
Thursday alone to kill a campaign
promise with this data there is not a
necessity of having a new bridge for
cars
now the project was announced in 2021 by
the premier along with a video outlining
the plan it would have been two levels
and six Lanes linking Quebec City with
Levy right now there are two Bridges but
they're side by side and both at the
Western end of the two cities the car
tunnel would have been at the Eastern
end the transportation Minister says
post pandemic traffic has dropped to the
point the project isn't needed instead
it's being scaled back and will only
involve public transit this is the right
decision to make now that doesn't mean
it's an easy decision to make in Las
Falls provincial election the tunnel was
a major issue for the region and some
candidates who promised it are coming
under Fire
cabinet minister Eric Cal promised to
fight for the project quote until his
last drop of blood
he now says he understands if people
feel betrayed
the education Minister choked back tears
talking about the turnaround the tunnel
would have connected his riding to
Quebec City he asked journalists to go
easy on him please don't let me talk
about it some more it's a little too
much
Quebec's Premier has made a calculation
that the next election is far enough
away that voters will forget observers
say he may be right but that might not
be his only challenge the main problem
for the CQ is not with voters it's about
internal a party Unity especially within
the caucus
the change of heart has been fodder for
opposition parties each of the other
three parties in the National Assembly
campaigned against a tunnel for cars
Quebec made a choice to lie to quebecers
now the original plan didn't have the
support of the federal government
Otto has a policy of not funding New
Roads the plan is it stands now public
transit only would qualify for federal
funding the question is whether the
support from the public is still there
Mike Armstrong Global News Montreal
drilling down into Dental Care coming up
the Federal government's Plan dentist
fear will leave a giant Gap
Universal Dental Care was a big ticket
item in this year's federal budget with
industry professionals welcoming
Investments to help Canadians access
care but as Catherine Ward reports some
caution there are other barriers to
access including a shortage of dental
assistance
it was a key part of the 2023 federal
budget I am so proud to announce the
creation of a new Canadian dental care
plan however Advocates say even with the
investment the industry is in a tough
spot the shortest Dental Assisting is uh
is the number one issue for dentists
across the country we are hearing that
over the next decade there are going to
be declining numbers of dental
hygienists as well but right now the
immediate concern is the the shortage of
dental assistance in 2019 before the
pandemic just over a third of dental
offices had unfilled dental assistant
positions from 2010 to 2020 the rate of
dental assistance entering the workforce
declined from three for every dentist to
just one dental assistants perform a
variety of tasks their job can include
greeting patients and clerical work but
more often the role Works alongside the
dentist during procedures as well as
sterilizing managing tools and materials
they're mixing those materials they're
they're handing them to us sometimes
they're doing part of the Hands-On work
themselves so we do rely on them a great
deal Kelly Mansfield has been a
certified dental assistant for 30 years
she says part of the reason many leave
including herself is because of poor
compensation and benefits I was a
certified level 2 dental assistant for
over 10 years and worked in private
practice
and I left because
I just couldn't live on on the salary of
a dental assistant so I did take my oral
health education and background and I
went into a different profession another
issue the association is concerned about
is untrained people filling the roles
the biggest risk would be that dentists
are hiring untrained individuals that
are being hired to fill the rule in the
operatory this is a significant third to
dental assistance and a significant
concern to the general public some hope
the federal investment will help fill
the Gap there is a section of the the
budget that talks about an oral health
care access fund and we hope that that's
an area where we can get some support to
increase the number of programs to train
dental assistants in the meantime with
more people now able to see the dentist
getting into the office might require
some weight Catherine Ward Global News
Toronto
I had taiwan's timeline we sit down with
the country's foreign minister talking
when not if China will attack
[Music]
with its latest military exercises
wrapped up China's recent show of
strength around Taiwan has ended but
that hasn't cooled tensions a delegation
of Canadian MPS also visited Taiwan
earlier this month meeting with its
president and other top officials and
during that visit our Jeff sempel sat
down with taiwan's foreign affairs
minister discussing the threat of a
potential Chinese Invasion and foreign
interference
several things we can say about the
Chinese military threat against Taiwan
the first is China used the pretext of
president's meeting with speaker
McCarthy of the U.S Congress but the
president has been visiting our
diplomatic allies all the time so this
time around there's no exception at all
and China use that as a pretext to
launch a major Medicare exercises
against Taiwan is unacceptable totally
unacceptable what China wants to do to
Taiwan is to eliminate taiwan's
international support but if you look at
Taiwan Taiwan is a democracy we have
rights to make friends and we want to
make friends the way we want to make one
of the areas that focuses for the
Canadian delegation is the discussion
about foreign interference taiwan's
experience with that we've seen in
recent weeks reports and revelations in
Canada alleging that the Chinese
government tried to interfere in recent
Canadian elections and what did you make
when you when you heard about those
reports well we saw the news of those
reports that China was trying to
interfere in the Canadian politics or
elections we feel that Canada is not at
all there are the countries many other
countries said China is trying to
interfere in their politics through this
information campaign or through this
abroad this Borah groups and Etc and the
Tony's people are saying that well we
have experienced all that and a lot more
and for many years already and therefore
we have developed some understanding of
the Chinese interference and if there's
any country who want to learn from
Taiwan the way we have gone through all
these kinds of problems and the way we
have learned our experiences we welcome
those kinds of requests for exchanges
and the Canadian delegation this time
around has been erasing that issue and
Taiwan is the vibrant democracy
especially represented by very active
engine
and there are some ngos who are very
active and very positive on these matter
they try to crack the Chinese
disinformation campaign and they try to
work with media they try to work with
the Taiwanese government and they have
become internationally renowned in
dealing with this information a lot of
intelligence officials you know academic
experts is the refrain you hear a lot is
that it's not a matter of if but when
the Chinese military will will try and
move on Taiwan what do you think I think
I would agree with some of the analysis
it might be 2025 2027 or 2035 and Etc
there's some marriage to those analysis
but from our perspective you know we
should not wait for those years to come
we should be prepared and we're trying
to get prepared whenever an
authoritarian state has a problem
domestically like economic slowdown
domestic discontent they may find a
scapegoat outside the country to create
a crisis in order to divert the domestic
attention or to keep the country
together and for Taiwan you know we are
so conveniently located right next to
China and we are concerned to be a
China's scapegoat their ambition uh and
they're at you know expansionism has
been noticed by many countries like the
United States Canada Japan Australia and
Etc their ambition is over all Pacific
their ambition is over Indian Ocean as
well so these kinds of Highly
provocative and expansionist type of
behavior should be met with the
opposition and under these kinds of
circumstances when the authoritarianism
is continuing to expand if we flash back
to the Second World War
and look at the origin of the second
world war is one country one man pointed
to one territory and said that is mine
and that is mine and they go grab it it
is the same situation in this part of
the world somebody is saying that
demonstrate is mine Taiwan is mine East
China Sea is mine and South China Sea is
mine and they want to go grab it
this is very dangerous and we should
stop them from doing this Minister thank
you so much
I appreciate it very much for being
interested in speaking with me
[Music]
a special space for black students next
how one room is making great strides for
inclusivity at Toronto metropolitan
University
[Music]
like so many institutions these days the
university in the heart of Canada's
biggest city is a place in transition
Toronto metropolitan University is
taking steps to tackle its racist
history and imagine a future Beyond its
former namesake
the University was originally named
Ryerson after Edgerton Ryerson
considered an architect of Canada's
residential school system for years the
school faced calls to reevaluate its
Heritage and a task force was formed in
2020 and then it all came to a head in
2021 during Canada's racial Reckoning
over unmarked Graves discovered at a
former BC residential school that
sparked protests and activists toppled
Ryerson statue on campus the statue was
never restored and the university
changed its name months later as part of
the task force recommendations now tmu
is seeking to be a more inclusive space
that Pioneers change and that can take
shape in many forms even if it simply
means just having a safe place to hang
out
this is the stressful season for
students at Toronto metropolitan
University but there's something new
this year intended to better support one
of the school's historically
underrepresented groups like the room
itself isn't really nothing special just
just a room it's mostly just the people
the vibe that like is brought into this
room that keeps me coming here
decompressing prepping and sharing the
everyday experiences that are unique to
them as black students I kind of just
look out for other black students to try
and get to know them because obviously
there's not many of us at least in
chemical engineering and having
conversations that make him feel less
alone just being black it's always been
like a little bit of a pressure to try
and outperform like others
the school's black student lounge was
developed out of a recommendation from a
2020 anti-black racism campus review
that found black students face racism
from their peers and the school itself
including exclusionary admission
practices and concerns with policing on
campus the lounge is available to block
identifying students and staff who are
asked to complete an access form to gain
entry I was recently talking to a
student and I'll quote them here because
I think it's such an important point
that in the black student lounge they
get to just be themselves and outside of
the lounge they're black students the
University of British Columbia is also
pioneering a similar program it's
Vancouver campus started the male black
initiative last year as a confidential
space for black men to connect it's one
thing to recruit black students here
there's nothing to stay here and if you
don't feel comfortable staying here if
you don't feel like you belong chances
are you may not compete your education
the schools have heard criticism the
spaces exclude students who aren't black
leaders from Toronto metropolitan say
that's not the point these universities
part of how we create them is to say we
make them for everybody but the very
systems in which these institutions are
built often the dominant classes are
predominant
they have more access and then the
actual institutions they have more voice
it's a great place to be I love it here
yeah I'm glad it is here because I don't
know what I would be doing
if it wasn't one of the biggest things
that I've seen or one of the biggest
shifts that I've seen in students who
have come into that into this space is
their confidence to navigate University
overall empowering students to not just
survive these pressure-filled years but
to thrive
and that's global national for this
Sunday night I'm Farah Nasser and on
behalf of our whole crew I want to thank
you so much for spending quite a few or
Sunday evening with us here tonight's
your Canada is Lake Winnipeg near Gimli
Manitoba until tomorrow take care of
yourselves and take care of each other
good night
thank you